[Music]
did you see he's gained some weight and
he's got the sparkle back in his eyes
he's clearly doing it better I don't
know why are you hiding everything we
said we weren't going to do this again
remember I agree that weren't Christmas
you get a day this time tomorrow you are
back in sober living yeah okay you did
not leave my sight ever because for the
next 24 hours you are mine all mine got
it I got it he burns I thought you were
dead I put my family in danger this is
on you if I don't deal with this then it
could be worse next time look okay you
go in pay the man and get right back out
lock the door I can't be calm
you need to go home if you really knew
me you'd be done with me we know you no
no you don't mom you don't know me
unlock the door bin right now I told you
not to believe me and you didn't listen
[Music]
all I need is for you to do me just one
more v Romeo
I'm looking for my son I can tell
there's something wrong you need to come
here not without Ben
I just need you to place and find my son
things that I've done to myself and
others we can't save them but you'll
hate yourself if you don't try
just tell me son where you want me to
bury you I'm not going to die
anyways Here I am still here so thank
you thank you for me if I sink or swim
[Music]